am Ende geht es um die Frage warum haben
wir zum Beispiel ein handwerkermangel in
Deutschland ich glaube und das ist meine
These heute abend dass die Regierung uns
gar nicht sagt so richtig wie schlechtes
um dieses Land eigentlich steht also sie
sagt uns oder malt das Land in einem
besseren Farben als es ist denn eins ist
klar uns gehen die Jobs aus nicht die
Jobs aber uns gehen die Arbeitskraft das
ist der Punkt in 10 Jahren werden nach
berechnungsinstituts der deutschen
Wirtschaft und 5 Millionen Menschen zu
wenig bei uns am Arbeitsmarkt sein das
hat damit zu tun dass immer mehr
Menschen in Rente gehen aber zu wenig
junge Menschen in den Arbeitsmarkt
Streben und auch die andere Regierung
Herr Maja ich muss das leider sagen
setzt die falschen Anreize mit dem
Bürgergeld beispielsweise sicherlich
nicht dazu beiträgt den Druck einen Job
anzunehmen zu erhöhen und auch mit dem
Thema Rente da sehen wir gerade was das
Thema höhere und längere Arbeitszeit
Lebensarbeitszeit angeht dass ich auch
die ampelregierung mit Beteiligung der
FDP nicht so richtig durchdringen kann
auch da was zu tun dass insgesamt mehr
Menschen im Arbeitsmarkt verbleiben so
dass wir das Problem was sie auch gerade
ansprechen hast den zum Beispiel
handwerkermangel damit lösen könnten
also zum einen bin ich ein Schäfer
dankbar dass er das Thema angesprochen
hat das ist um Deutschland nicht so gut
steht wie man vielleicht in der
öffentlichen Debatte den Eindruck
bekommen kann wenn man ehrlich sind ist
das ein Thema was seit zehn Jahren
schleichend Entwicklung ist wir haben
in den letzten zehn Jahren Steuer
Mehreinnahmen auf Bundesebene von 100
Milliarden Euro erwirtschaftet jährlich
weil es der Wirtschaft gut ging weil es
viele Arbeitsplätze gab weil damit viel
Steuern bezahlt wurden weil wenig sozial
Transfers ausgeschlossen
zehn Jahre und das ist auch das
Erfolgsrezept was wir in den nächsten
Jahren deswegen bin ich ja auch
vollkommen bei ihnen sicherstellen
müssen wir müssen wieder für mehr
Wirtschaftswachstum sorgen wir müssen
aus dieser Krise jetzt mit mehr
Wirtschaftswachstum rauskommt mit mehr
Menschen die in Beschäftigung und das
aber das ist die Lösung das ist zum
Fachkräftemangel wir haben seit
Jahrzehnten gesagt wir sind ein
Einwanderungsland wir müssen
qualifizierte Zuwanderung ermöglichen es
kommt unqualifizierung aber zumindest
ist es so dass auch da die
Vorgängerregierung dieses Thema nicht
angegangen sind wir müssen mehr Menschen
weil die geboten raten in Deutschland so
sind wie sie sind an qualifizierten
Zuzug ermöglichen um genau diese
Arbeitsplätze die zukünftig nicht mehr
besetzt werden können besetzen zu können
wir müssen
weiter zu das unqualifizierte Migration
stattfindet jeden Tag und nicht und der
Punkt ist
qualifizierten Kräfte kommen nicht nach
Deutschland wenn Sie feststellen dass
sie keine Rente mehr bekommen in einem
System dass Sie einzahlen müssen wenn
sie aufrecht haben deswegen haben wir
die aktienrente jetzt gestartet wir
werden am Ende des Tages glaube ich wir
sind gar nicht so weit auseinander wir
müssen gucken dass wir mehr Arbeits den
Arbeitsmarkt mehr
Arbeitskräfte zur Verfügung stellen dann
müssen wir alle Potenzial einstellen
eine Steuerentlastung haben wir gerade
mit dem Abbau der kalten Progression
gemacht er sagt aber ja
richtig aber wir haben 45 Milliarden
Euro letztlich das hätte man vor einem
Jahr auch nicht geglaubt dass diese
Koalition 45 Milliarden Euro im
einkommensteuerbereich entlastet durch
eine Erhöhung des Grundfreiheit warum
ich will sie gar nicht warum weil wir
eine extrem hohe Inflation haben und das
Gesetz ist vorsieht also gehen muss
nicht vor sondern die FDP hat es
durchgesetzt in harten Kämpfen mit den
Koalitionspartnern es gab andere
Koalitionspartner Tarif anzupassen es
ist leider keine gesetzliche Frist wir
haben es nicht in Koalitionsvertrag
verhandeln können wir haben uns damit
durchgesetzt und das ist natürlich ein
Thema das gehört zu Ehrlichkeit dazu
dass wir in der Ampel drei
schreib Parteien haben die natürlich
diametral andere programmatische Ansätze
verfolgen wir immer gesagt uns geht es
um die Entlastung der Menschen deswegen
war das Thema Abbau der kalten
Progression Steuerentlastung für uns ein
zentrales genau wir müssen einmal
erklären klingt so technisch dass man
einmal sagt der Staat hat Milliarden
mehr Einnahmen dadurch dass es eine
Inflation gibt die extreme ist mit der
Mehrwertsteuer und was jetzt passiert
ist nichts anderes als zu sagen dass das
wird deswegen mehr abschöpfen
beispielsweise darüber Lohnerhöhung das
geben wir den Menschen zurück das heißt
unterm Strich muss man sagen keine
Entlastung eigentlich nur ein fairer
Ausgleich ich glaube so viel müssen wir
sein aber wie dokumentieren andere
Partner in in dieser Koalition wollten
das nicht sondern wollten das Geld der
politische Preis den Sie bezahlt haben
das ist natürlich ein Thema wo wir alle
in jeder Koalition immer eine Situation
haben dass es Kompromisse gibt es ist
kein Geheimnis dass beim Thema
Bürgergeld wir im Bereich Bürgergeld als
FDP immer gesagt haben dass wir die
Zuverdienstgrenzen dann könnte das ein
Kompromiss bis zur Selbstaufgabe auch
irgendwann bedeuten nein bestimmt nicht
weil am Ende des Tages die FDP in den
letzten Jahren ja klar gemacht hat das
ist halt Punkte gibt Stichwort
Schuldenbremse zum Beispiel wo wir nicht
bereit sind eine Änderung aber
bevorzugen
so das heißt es gibt rote Linien die wir
gestern
in den Koalition
ähm Vertrag und dazu stehen wir und
deswegen geht es nicht darum dass wir
über Selbstaufgabe reden sondern es gibt
in dieser Koalition die unterschiedliche
thematische Ansätze hat immer auch ein
Ringen um die richtige Lösung und ich
glaube die FDP Ansätze da drin
verhindern zumindest schlimmeres wenn
man die Programmatik von den anderen
Partnern anguckt und da ist genau das
Thema
Wirtschaftswachstum das Thema Fachkräfte
Zuwanderung das Thema Qualifizierung das
Thema Flexibilisierung des
Renteneintrittsalters ein Thema was die
FDP immer sehr anspricht
das war eine gute Wahlkampfrede herr
Meier ja genau also ihre Loyalität
übrigens zu ihrer Partei die merkt man
aus jeder Pore das ist was sehr
positives heutzutage mit mit durchgehen
lassen sie haben ja mitgestimmter
Koalition und auf der anderen Seite
reden sie davon dass wir mehr Fachkräfte
in der Produktion brauchen wie wird denn
dann Schuh draußen also zum Thema
Bürgergeld wir haben leider nur drei
Sätze für die Antwort wegen der
Sendezeit schade also
Bürgergeld hat einige sehr positive
Aspekte Zuverdienstgrenze wird angehoben
damit Leute mehr arbeiten und nicht von
staatlichen Jugendlichen bei älteren
Menschen und was die Erhöhung der
Regelsätze angeht das ist ein
Inflationsausgleich der vorgezogen wurde
der will ja sogar die CDU jetzt
mitmachen so dass wir am Ende im
Vermittlungsausschuss hoffe ich ein
einen guten Kompromiss hinkriegen der
das was vielleicht in dem Entwurf noch
nicht so gut war ähm Stichwort
vielleicht Karenzzeiten in der richtige
Richtung
Patienten oder für ältere Leute ersetzen
doch keine Fachkräfte die gebraucht
werden
dass Menschen die von ALG2 momentan
leben
Anreiz haben etwas dazu zu verdienen um
dann irgendwann in der Situation zu
kommen dass sie nicht mehr auf
Transferleistungen angewiesen sind